we'll see
hello nice to meet you good to see you
thank you so much thank you for having
me you're welcome good to see you
okay
thank you please
um
we have uh made clear
the clear preference for finding a
diplomatic resolution to
the
conflict and to de-escalate
the
the situation
that is
the
clear preference it's also the most
responsible thing
that any of us can do
at the same time we've made very clear
to moscow that if it chooses to renew
aggression against uh against ukraine uh
it will be met and it will face very
severe consequences and again that's
coming not just from the united states
but from countries across europe and
beyond as you all know very very well uh
we have been engaged in the past couple
of months in
an intense focus on ukraine because of
the
significant buildup we've seen of
russian forces
near the ukrainian border
no provocation
no reason
except that we have a very significant
force
we know that there are plans in place to
increase that force even more on very
short notice
and that gives
president putin the capacity
uh also on very short notice uh to take
further aggressive action uh against
ukraine and
that of course has gotten not only our
attention but it's gotten the attention
of
virtually all of our allies and partners
and not just in europe even beyond and
as you all know very well because you're
working this every day
we have tried to make clear that there
are two paths
for
for russia there is the path of
diplomacy and dialogue to try to resolve
whatever differences there are
peacefully through diplomacy clearly the
preferable path clearly the most
responsible path and the one that we
would prefer
but there is also the the path if russia
chooses to renew aggression
of confrontation and consequences
for russia and we have been working
to build out both of those paths in very
close coordination and collaboration
with uh with allies and partners
the president
asked me to come now to both reaffirm
our own commitment to ukraine to consult
closely with its leaders
as well tomorrow in berlin to speak to
many of our european colleagues and then
finally
on friday to see the russian foreign
minister to take stock of where we are
after a week of what's been very intense
diplomacy between the united states and
russia at the nato-russia council
and at the osce
so we'll see where we are
at the end of the week and again i
strongly strongly hope that we can
keep this on a diplomatic
and uh
peaceful path but ultimately
that's going to be president putin's
decision